recevoir des messages de soutien
C'est surprenant, n'est-ce pas Gens des Forces d'Autodéfense
Mais juste cette camisole de force
C'est étrange de dire ça, mais
Parce que c'est une action constitutionnelle.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont des démangeaisons
je vois que tu es là
[musique]
Je veux jouer le même rôle que l'énergie noire
En bref, la défense territoriale
je vais avec mes envies
Je suis celui qui défend le territoire et protège le pays.
C'est au milieu de la journée, et tu es désespéré
Par exemple, la nationalité
Même si c'est différent
défense territoriale
Je me demande aussi ce que fait le président
Ukrainien lui-même
Bref, je fais de mon mieux pour protéger la terre
C'est un point
Hé
[musique]
juste parce que je viens du japon
Je ne sais pas ce que ressentent les Ukrainiens
Je me demande si je peux devenir plus fort
Je peux le sentir quand je marche dans la rue S'il te plait viens souvent
Parce que vous pouvez dire quelque chose comme
Ce pays veut aider quelque chose
j'arrive
Eh bien, je suis désolé si c'est un terme impropre, mais ce genre de chose
L'idée est l'accomplissement dans un sens.
[musique]